it's been a very crazy week for the ncaa
a week that i don't think we'll fully
appreciate the ramifications of
for a while it began on monday with the
us supreme court making it clear the
business model is an anti-trust
violation it is a walking talking
breathing crapping antitrust violation
and yesterday there was another court
ruling in a case involving i think a
swimmer from arizona state and a female
basketball player from oregon
that that just further underscores that
the world is changing for the ncaa and
the biggest challenge right now the name
image and likeness rules that the ncaa
is scrambling to deal with because the
whole the whole idea
that players cannot
generate revenue
from the fame that they have realized
whether it's playing college sports or
high school or whatever else tick tock
wherever they've become famous you can't
make any money from that that has to go
away that that that is just the extra
little thing the ncaa does to boost up
this goofy notion of amateur athletics
oh nobody can make any money and the
longer they delay this big cat the the
more expensive it's going to be
the greater that the final verdict is
going to be in the class action lawsuit
and they are really stuck here and i
think they're just coming to terms with
the idea we've got to open the
floodgates and let all these athletes go
out and make whatever money they can
make off of their name their image and
their likeness and that's all coming
next thursday one day before aaron
rodgers opts out for the entire 2021
season so is everyone getting paid next
year explain that to me mike like i am
five years old because i'm obviously i
think everybody's getting paid next week
everyone's getting paid next week i
think as of july one
i think july one
once once they wave that fly is it the
checkered flag or the white flag what's
the flag to start the race is it a white
flag once they wave the flag to start
the race next thursday green
green flag it's a green flag all right
green flag once they wave the green flag
next thursday
anyone can do business with anyone else
uh and this is the way it's moving there
are six states that are making name
image and likeness rules effective next
week the ncaa is realizing the longer we
tell
these kids they can't do it the more
liability we're going to be exposed to
after this supreme court ruling that
shows the whole thing's an anti-trust
violation all these rules that tell
schools what they can't do by way of
giving players benefits or letting them
make money from their fame is an
anti-trust violation all these different
universities coming together and
agreeing
we're you know we're going to fix the
price of our labor that's basically the
argument so it's the floodgates open
next next thursday i haven't said arch
manning if he wants to if you know uncle
payton decides to take him under his
wing and show him a few things about
business arch manning can start selling
jerseys put his face on things posters
whatever autograph appearances you can
make money however you see fit it
becomes free enterprise as of next
thursday subject to some i'm sure there
will be some
effort to apply rules and restrictions
and maybe protect people from charlatans
but why not look it's why not what
think of how think of how bizarre it is
that
let's say if you're
17 years old and you're an actor or a
singer or some other celebrity you can
make as much money as you want however
you want off of anyone who wants to do
business with you
to leverage your fame into revenue
why has it ever been
that just because you play a sport and
your fame derives from that that you're
not allowed to do it is ridiculous when
you think about it yeah no it's been
ridiculous for a very long time there's
very few people that stand on the other
side being like hey this is this is bad
this is bad for the kids i think there's
like maybe four people left
um
but i i guess
i don't understand how they're going to
uh keep the rules there because
from what you just said to me the light
bulb went off in my head
that uh you know if if penn national
stock goes through the roof
someday i will be hiring a bunch of
interns
that happen to be five-star recruits
uh who want to play at the university of
wisconsin is that what you're saying to
me because i am down for that
i i i think let me take it even a step
farther than that because one thing that
dawned on me this week
now look this is all subject to whatever
rules get put in place and
the ncaa wants congress desperately to
come in and create a nationwide standard
so the ncaa can say hey we don't have
anything to do with it it's not an
anti-trust violation if congress says
these are the rules but
why would
a 17 18 19 year old athlete be
prohibited in a state
where gambling is legal
from doing an endorsement deal with a
sports book what's what's wrong with
that now in the nfl you can't do it
because the antitrust violations
disappear under the cover of the union
relationship the nfl can have rules
without creating an anti-trust problem
by saying players aren't allowed to do a
deal with draftkings fanduel points bet
penn national whoever
you open these nil floodgates
you don't have to even you don't have to
make up a phony job you can just say hey
oh yeah kid's going to wisconsin he's
going to be a an ambassador
great for the penn national brand and
i'm paying him 100 grand a year i love
this i want to be a booster mike i
really do i want to be a
somewhat shady booster i i really
i'm actually a little the downside to
this with these rules
is like i kind of wanted to be a shady
booster i wanted to be boosting it and
and you know have it be a big thing that
blows up in my face i think that would
have been fun it would have been a fun
chapter in my life now it sounds like i
can do this all
above board above the table legally yeah
like so i i don't know i'm actually a
little bummed i think i'm on the side of
these rules kind of stink now
but you know what
there's some there's some
truth embedded in this that i think is
going to work to the disadvantage of the
wisconsins and the west virginians of
the world because what's going to happen
now
again those two things are how they can
figure out how to those two things i
know but it's
but but wait is chicago in wisconsin now
i mean no but i'm just saying
yeah those two things aren't the same
but here's go ahead here's my point
here's my here's my point
the universities
that have the largest concentration of
supporters boosters really rich people
who will gladly take the tax right off
under the guise of doing a bad deal a
bad endorsement deal hey i got my car
dealership and the quarterback of the
football team is gonna have his face on
every ad that i do and i'm gonna pay him
500 grand even though that is a horrible
use of my marketing budget i don't care
my point is for the universities that
have more people bigger population
center more of these boosters floating
around who are willing to do bad
business deals those schools are going
to become more attractive because
they're going to have more resources
through their no longer shady boosters
now you could argue well okay you know
they should have been profiting all
along because they can have more shady
boosters i think it changes when it's
all above board and you can go out and
recruit your boosters
to to get into this kind of business and
essentially funnel money to the players
and and look there's going to have to be
a subtlety to it but but it's going to
change everything it really is going to
change everything wherever it goes
however it goes it's not going to kill
college football but it's definitely
going to change it it's not nothing can
kill college football i mean it won't be
won't die because the tradition and the
history and
the amount of people that care about it
it's always going to be there in some
iteration
it's funny that you say all that because
then imagine like in 20 years yale wins
a national title yale beats alabama
because if you're talking about just
pure
you know money
uh donors all these things wouldn't that
wouldn't you then say that the ivy
leagues are now going to be
we're going to go back in time it's
going to basically be the turn of the
century not this turn of century but the
one before it's going to be 1900 and
it's going to be it's going to be
harvard versus yale for the national
title
well
no i i
i mean i mean you just said you just
said the most about the teams you know
the most attractive teams will be the
alumni with the most money those uh an
ivy league alumni and the endowment that
they have is off the charts compared to
to any anywhere else right
let me just say this from the
perspective of someone who tried to get
into an ivy league law school and failed
30-plus years ago you got to be able to
be to be you know eligible to go to the
school there aren't many people smart
enough to get into the ivy league
schools so
i i think that reduces the universe of
guys that you're going to get there no
matter what in this day and age plain
and simple so
and and and also i don't know that the
harvard and the yale grads out there
with a lot of money are going to be
willing to start peeling off 100 grand
here and 100 grand there to boof up to
beef up the the football basketball
teams but i i've been some of them
we'll be dead in the ground by the time
it happens but maybe our kids and
grandkids will
realize that instead of clemson and
alabama it'll be harvard and yale every
year in the ncaa championship yeah i
mean it's
the way you described it if i i don't
think that's obviously going to happen
but it is an interesting dynamic that
like the alumni of where did where did
jeff bezos go to college did he go to
college we need to figure that out he
went to wisconsin i think i don't know i
feel like he was one of those guys who
dropped out like like that isn't it
what does it say about the college
system that the most ridiculously
successful people in society
all realized at some point during that
four-year period i'm getting the hell
out of here
i just you know food for thought sounds
like they didn't have fun at college
yeah that's what it sounds like to me
they're having
to the moon now
you